好 今天由我俩来给大家讲一下买点体系的建设与治理以及AB的部分然后前半场我们先围绕买点体系的建设与治理分享一下我们的一些工作经验和实践然后我这边先简单的给大家介绍一下我们整个知乎的买点链路然后买点链路的话其实先给大家解释几个名词吧
就是其实数据上报层这一块大家应该都很熟悉其实就是我们端上的同学用的各种各样的 SDK 嘛然后日治代理层的话其实就是啊几个日治的接触服务我们这边其实是分为了 zlog server和 data hub这么两块啊然后一会我来单独介绍他们的区别然后呢接下来一层叫消息堆裂层就是我们说的卡不卡这种 MQ
然后这块的话其实主要是做一个这个消息的缓冲然后呢再到下游的这一部分其实就到了这个基础数仓这边的一些动作了比如说etl etl其实就是这个数据的抽离转换以及load的过程然后它其实会对这个数据进行一些初步的这种加工处理然后再往下呢就是我们的hive或者是doris这种这个数据存储
和OLAB的数据查询引擎和一些骑士服务从上层我再详细去说一下其实知乎这边的话其实分为知乎主战主战的话主要是H5小程需要Web这些还有知乎的主App然后以及其他的一些小的App整体上我们其实根据端可以分为GS SDK然后双端的RSN主SDK然后当然我们还有AP SDK也会有一些数据的相报
然后这里面其实分成了两个通道我们这边有一个叫实时通道就是我们所谓Data Hub这一块来承载它的然后它的下游的MQ的订阅者其实是偏向于去做实时的一些服务就是这边也是有一个ETL然后下游介入Dauris再到下游其实就是对应的一些比如说我们的机器学习然后算法推荐
等等的这样的一个服务然后再回来除了实时通道之外的剩余的所有的日治其实会上报到我们的Zlog Server这上面这上面其实我们会做一些独立机的独立部署主要是为了做一些融灾比如说我当下游的MQ发生一些问题的时候其实我Zlog Server可以通过一个Level DB来进行栽培的换存
然后当这个数据就在mqq重新恢复之后我的这些数据其实还是在的所以还可以继续把它捡起来往下游去传然后整个etl这一块呢其实它会做一些基础的处理你比如说我们在app端其实去抓取一个数据的时候它可能不一定会那么的完整或者说那么的健全
举个简单的例子比如说我的一个NTP时间NTP就是通过网络获取的网络实施时间那它肯定是一个异步的那实际上我们在发送到服务端的
起初的比如说我的App刚开始的时候我可能有一个APS大的这种一个事件那这个事件里面的NTP时间肯定是空的因为它实际太早了那这个时候其实ETR就可以去做一些比如说根据一个时间窗口和你这个设备的一些信息找到第一个你能拿到NTP时间的同时结合你这个这个客户端的时间的一个坐标然后把前面的几条日子给你回补上
類似這樣的一個動作再比如說我的這個日治它是不是一個強交互類型的那其實是不需要段上去埋的那通過ETL的流程它其實可以寫一些邏輯去擴展一下這個表然後比如說直接告訴你它是一個這個強交互類型的或者說是一個用戶代表用戶能活躍的這麼一個事件對對我有一個疑問就是
我们在端上sdk调用的时候其实没有埋过那个isactive log这个点其实我们端上没有埋但是在我们的那个硕仓里通过那个叫circule查询的时候我们会发现有这个字段所以它是不是就通过etl进行处理的
对 没错就是整个这个字段的话其实是有一段逻辑其实之前跟书仓的老师们请教过就是我们这个字段是怎么来的其实他们对应的也是一段代码的处理那其实他拿到mq里面的一条message的时候他会把这个message解析出来然后对应的你比如说他是不是一个点击他是不是一个页面曝光啊如果是我只是举个简单例子啊如果是那他就会把这个事件他标记为一个
就是exactivity的一个exactivity的一个这种事件然后存起来大概是这个样子对对对就是整个链路其实就是我们数据上报程就是我们业务开发直接通过买点stk然后进行数据上报然后打到我们的data hub和lay log server就打到我们的服务器然后服务器再通过一些流程打到我们的数据仓库这样就会
从我们端上一直到数据仓库应该就是这样一个整体的链路过程是吧对 没错大概是这样子的然后其实这一块的话我们现在Dlock Server和Data Hub它其实承载了不一样的业务一个是承载偏离线的一个是承载偏这种实时的实际上他们有一部分的数据是荣誉的所以整体上来说我们
其实理论上是可以把二者和二为一的然后再下游再去做这种分拆其实理论上它的性能还有它对于客户端的有好度可能会更高对这个也是接下来可能我们会要去做的一些事情大概是这样然后这是整体数据链路的部分然后整个这块其实后面还会有一些设计到然后我后面再去详细讲解然后
对然后我们先从这个买点模型的设计来讲一个就因为我们啊 着重点还是讲买点的sdk嘛那买点sdk其实对应的第一个事情就是你要把买点的模型设计好那其实在每一家公司肯定都有啊
一些自己设计出来的买点模型在这里说买点模型其实是一个非常重要的概念就是如果你们哪家公司如果想做买点的成构你们一定要想清楚买点模型是非常重要的因为刚才讲到这个链路里面其实我们各个节点其实都要处理你的买点模型都是基于你的买点模型来做一些加工处理包括ETR的流程包括这个书仓的键表对吧
跟你的字段各种都是对应的包括你的那个就是比如说偏实实的这种推荐那其实跟你的买点模型也是有绑定关系的所以基本上你的买点模型固定下来之后其实你只能继续upend的一些逻辑就不可能去做大的修改了所以在这里说就是买点模型的前期设计是非常非常重要的但除了这个说它前期设置
前期设计完之后它很重要还有另外一个原因就是如果你设计的不是足够的进状那其实对于后续的一些比如说我们买点验证的过程我们整个买点设计的时候我怎么样去附用啊怎么样去把这些买点标记出来等等的一系列的工作其实都会带来一些负担当然你的买点模型设计得非常好的话这些问题
就可以比较容易的去解决对然后稍等一下我刚才就是理解一下刚才那个整体链路就是从端上一直存到数据库其实我们在做开发的时候发现数据库操作其实是很敏感的因为我们要进行数据库升级因为一旦一个字段设计错误了我们很难去修改数据库所以买点模型一旦设计完成之后就是
很难再去修改某些资段或者什么东西是不是早期的买点模型设计如果不好的话
对后面整体都是一个灾难而且后续想改也很难是的是非常非常大的灾难其实就是有很多我们天天说这个高内级第五核嘛其实系统啊然后这个买点模型设计啊等等的其实都是相通的嘛就比如说你设计的买点模型本身啊它也可以有一些扩展性但如果说你前期设置的一些
比如说你的模型非常固化的话那其实也是后期也是成本很高的你最起码说你要改一个东西可能要涉及到全联录这个东西可能需要一个非常强有力的角色在这才能推动而且它是一个公司级别的事情对公司级别的事情它非常的费力但是的ROI可能在每一个团队来评审的话可能也不一定能达成一致所以整条而言
就是前期的设计非常非常重要OK那你也为大佬给我们介绍一下如何设计一个现状的买点模型好然后当然了这个也是提前声明一下这个不一定完全是知乎的一个买点模型设计因为近几年我都在做买点SDK相关的一些事情嘛所以就结合相关的各个公司的一些时间吧来大概讲一下整个买点是怎么样被设计出来的对
然后首先来说其实我们买一点其实说白了就是收集用户的行为那用户的行为其实我们可以用4WH来描述就比如说你是谁你从什么时间产生的从哪里产生的然后用什么方式产生的还有你对某个你做了什么其实说白了就是你做了什么那户的话其实对应的比如说你的设备标识你的用户标识其实这些都是相对静态的一些信息
问的话其实说白了就是这个事件产生的时间但这个时间的话可能有几个纬度比如说刚才提到的一个NTP时间比如说当然这种其实大大部分的用户其实它的client time其实是已经被调整过的因为你比如说iOS三桌其实它会有一个自动时间调整吗
你只要打开client他们一般都是准的但我们可能会有个别的用户他没有一个精准的客户端时间所以我们会加一个NTP的时间还有比如说我发送的时间就是从客户端取到指发送的服务器的时间节点以及服务端接收到several time整个这几个时间你有了之后其实就可以去做一些事情比如说你去看你的计压的平均市场
你看你到达服务器的这个RTT啊对吧你到达服务器之后的处理时间等等的这都可以去做啊那这这引申到另外一个话题了待会再详细去说啊问的话其实在sdk内部其实也基本上都能做到啊然后我要的话就更不用说了比如说你的ip啊你的gps信息啊包括你app名字啊等等的这些其实也不需要说开发者在具体的埋怜里去做
哈务也是一样的哈务其实对应的就是你的外部也是怎么样打开这个App对吧比如说我是通过一个软链然后或者我是通过一个铺石打开了一个App那其实我会把这些信息都记录下来然后其实我们最需要让这个研发或者业务需要去关心的就是What我们对什么元素做了什么东西那这个事情的话其实我们需要把它管理起来大家管理起来
的目的是什么呢就是为了规范我们后期的这个买点啊他的上报质量啊因为你只有有了这样的原数据你才能利用这些原数据生成对应的规则去教育我们的买点对对其实前面几个就是前面的呃三w一哈我理解这个买点sdk就可以帮我们做对对其实真正需要业务做的应该就是water
对,没错,对,所以water就是很重要,应该是所有就是它设计的如果合理的话,其实整个买点SDK应该会设计的很规范,很健壮对,是这样的,所以其实我们的重中之重就是设计water是什么,对,然后呢,给大家讲一下这个出现的资源位,就是
是阿里吧还是谷歌之前有个SPM的一个模型就是超级自愿位实际上大部分你去描述一个用户行为的时候可能第一件事情就是你要知道用户操作的是哪个空间对吧或者用户操作的是什么样的一个元素你要把元素描述出来所以这里面就有一个自愿位的设计然后从我的角度来出发呢其实大概可以分这么
五个维度吧就是APP比如说你是一个但这个sdk的设计首先来说你肯定是属于一家公司的那这家公司可能有多个app所以呢最基本的我们会有一个app级别的数据对吧然后呢在app的下一级可能就会牵扯到这个频道频道的话比如说你是会员啊你还是这个社区啊他会分属到不同的部门去对吧
可能这个信息也是比较重要然后接下来就是页面级别比如说你这个会员业务里面有哪些页面然后这些页面它可能都会有自己的一些属性和特征所以会有一个页面的管理然后页面下面其实就是页面里面的元素你可以把它出现成模块然后这个叫法就无所谓大家知道这样一个东西就好了然后在最下面就是你对这个动作做了你对这个模块
或者对这个元素你做了什么当然这个动作可以发生在上面的几个层级的任何一个部分所以一个买点综合起来就是一个App级别的加上一个Channel级别加上一个Page级别加上一个Model级别加上一个Action其实基本上就能把你整个用户做了什么描述出来了对所以这样的话其实你可以精准定位它操作的是那个元素
然后你也可以对它的位置进行一些运营和对应的这种效果的查验对然后它也会方便管理和验证为什么呢因为刚才说了一个买点其实是这些东西的组合那这些东西的组合就唯一确定一种场景那在这种场景下比如说你的参数你的这些环境信息都可以非常规范的让它预知到你的买点平台上去对所以这样的话我们就可以去交易了
但是其实里面有个字段我觉得特别有意思就是这个channel就是某一个部门的东西对然后我们当时如果我们做了某一个买点对整个的那个app的收益有提高其实我们就可以它不仅就是我们可以直接通过在数据库中select新from channel等于某个部门比如首页的一个社区部门然后它
对整个大盘做了什么东西然后如果某一个数据质量出问题了我们也可以直接定位到某个channel就是某一个部门这样其实无论是在衡量某个部门的收益还是它的问题都会更方便一点我之前公司没有这个channel的概念现在来了之后觉得有这个channel的概念还挺有意思的对这个主要是对你刚才说的是其中一个很重要的部分就是
你能找到这个部门对吧找到部门其实你就可以对这个部门里面你看这个部门里一共有多少个点其实我们就可以做一些成本的分担其实每个部门对于买点的需求其实是不一样的
你的买点越多其实公司希望你做的贡献也越大嘛所以这个东西也是我们可以通过成本分单来说清楚的当然还有一个就是比如说如果我们的app非常大当然这个就是支付相对而言还不太需要做到这个channel的分流和资格意义但如果你的业务去这个用户量级或者说你的业务非常庞大的话其实你可以把通过channel把它直接
下放到不同的MQ里面去然后通过下游不同的ETR去处理这样的话其实你可能就不是一个综合性的大的收藏而是直接在这一层级就把它分成了一个个小的收藏就是每一个部门就是相当于一个收藏比如抖音啊他们的那个首页可能他的他的数据量会比其他部门的比如比我的或者账户的他的数据量明显的大特别多对其实通过这些东西也就可以做一些
针对部门的事情对没错没错呃据说抖音好像就是这么搞的就是他在这个channel级别也是这样来做的对还挺有意思然后呃所以刚才结合着上面的这个呃这些特征和他对应的这种层级的话其实我们就可以把事件基本上就抽离出来了抽象出来了
比如说APP这个级别的可能会有一些事件比如说APPOPEN CLOSE等等但CRASH EXIT也可以包含在里面它都是APP级的这些就是说这个后面其实对应的我们有一个资源标识服嘛就是APPNAME加一本的Type就能标识这个资源那比如说APPOPEN那其实你只要知道你的APPNAME其实你就知道那个APPOPEN嘛这个其实就不言而喻的对那再下来就是页面嘛
页面的话其实它就要结合App Name加Page ID加Event Type来定义你的唯一一个事件比如说知乎加上Page ID等于首页对吧加上Event Type等于Page Appear那其实你就定义了在知乎里面打开首页的这个动作关闭的话同理就是Date Appear这样对然后再下来可能就是一些模块的事件比如说点击啊曝光啊
然后滑动编辑等等的这些可能又会放到对应的这个某块里面去某块的标识服务可能就是更进一步就是在页面的基础上再加上某块的ID和这个某块所发生的动作基本上就描述出来了对一个某块的动作对大概是这个样子
然后这一页的话其实对应的还是上一页的延续对应的我们这些事件类型都有了它的位置标识服务其实刚才也大概介绍过了接下来其实有一个生命周期的概念你比如说App你打开一次App到结束一次App实际上
我们会有一个session的概念就是所谓的绘画周期从一个app打开一直到一个app关闭那实际上整个我们通过一个session把它的绘画的生命周期给它给它表示出来对页面也是像类似的你比如说我从页面从首页进到详情页然后我又回到首页那实际上首页是曝光了两次嘛那这两次你要想区分它
我们可以叫一个配置Request ID的概念当然这个的话名字无所谓大家就知道这样有一个时空标识服务来标识它当前的这一次动作就好了应该是这一次请求这次在面前请求对对没错当然了叫Request ID但不代表说它一定会重新请求它可能只是重新曝光对对对
然后模块呢其实就不会有单独的这样的生命中期了因为它是依附于页面之上的嘛所以它会带上页面的这个UXID加上页面的这个PageID这样的话其实我们就能知道啊这个模块是发生于哪一次的页面曝光里面或者发生在哪个页面里面对然后
那其他的一些系统事件和其他的一些行为呢可能就是在这些事件上述的这些事件里面不能出现出来了那其实我们就可以把它全部归类到其他的事件里面这个主要是为了去满足一些比较特殊的case和场景对啊对有一个问题就是
其实这个数据模型我理解大家所有的APP都有APP的概念有PID的概念模块的概念其实大家如果都通用这一套概念的话其实所有公司可以共用一套Made in模型设计其实可能这个类设计完之后拿到另外一个公司可以直接用
如果就是形成一个行业规范的话其实一套买点模型是可以在任何公司直接横行的对这个真的就是一个比较理想态的一个东西了真的假如说大家有意识到当然今天我讲的也只是结合着我自己的一些经验来分享大家如果觉得自己公司对有更好的用买点模型实际上可以随时就是在群里去讨论的
就是我觉得这个东西如果真的像其他的一些开源项目一样有一个行业的最佳实践和最佳共识的话那其实离大一统就不远了我觉得是一个非常好的一个事情对然后那我觉得讲下面就是这个的话其实我就不多讲了就是这个大体就化了一下整个app的一个生命周期比如说一个app打开这深蓝色的就是一个app级别的一个事件就是从一个app launch
到APP close的过程当launch的时候其实首先可能就是首页通过网络请求或者本地缓存把首页的内容加在出来了然后它可能对这些内容进行了一些操作对应的就是页面曝光然后某块的曝光 某块的点击以及下个页面的跳转实际上整个通过这样一个模型就基本上把用户行为的时间线给描述出来了
那也能基本满足大部分的这种买点需求大概是这个样子然后再证明一下就是这个可能并不是我们之呼的一个买点数据的模型只是通过这样一个例子分享给大家一些比如说买点SDK内部的一些小心机对比如说我们现在进到一个页面然后这个页面可能需要你去打点你打点的内容是什么呢
页面肯定我们要有一个曝光的时间对吧这个曝光比如说这个是一个Page ShowPage Show的话你一定要告诉我Page Identifier就是它的页面的标识以及你承载的业务参数拿这个页面来说你一定要告诉我比如说它的内容类型和内容的ID是多少我通过内容类型和内容ID其实我可以去做一些分析比如说我的内容排行对吧哪些的页面曝光最高
等等的这些强调的分析所以业务方式要关心的就是页面的标识和业务参数然后社会鱼的这些其实里面绝大部分还是由SDK自动填充的比如说这一次页面曝光的RexID然后我们会通过UID的形式自动生成
然后包括它发生的时间当前App的信息启动来源的信息然后启动的C3ID等等的我们都会通过SDK自动给它填充当页面消失的时候SDK会自动集团市场并且携带此次的Request ID上报到DESAPIR然后这里面其实有一个有意思的点就是下游我刚才说到其实树仓那边会做一个ETL的预处理
就是数据加工是吧对对对数据加工的时候其实会把这个DSPR和配置寿进行合并其实DSPR这个事件所承载的唯一任务就是携带它的时长然后携带时长呢怎么样去跟那个配置寿去关联呢其实配置DSPR的时候我们在SDK层面会跟配置寿拿一样的Request ID这样的话其实我们通过Request ID就能把配置寿和DSPR进行
这个书仓层面的关联关联完成之后呢我们把dcp2里面那个时长贯到配置寿里面这样呢下游的使用的时候比如说我数据分析师在计算每一个内容他阅读时长的时候我就不用单独拿一个dcp2的事件去做了对吧那我其实直接可以拿去寿如果是之前的话如果不挺正的话就是水lake的拍接dcp2拿到一个时间抽
然后说它的功能是在把它相剪就得到它的时间对就是你整个加工的过程其实还是比较烦大了嘛所以就类似于这样的小信机其实可以就是减轻下游使用的成本就会低很多对对对那这里拿一个例子来举例啊比如说我们早期用到一些有盟当然这不是说有盟做得不好只是说
各家有各家的做法比如说有盟其实你可以去抓包什么的去看他的买点验证他其实也有买点验证的工具那他们是怎么做的呢他们其实是会给你两个时机就是展示和消失的时候让你打两个点那其实他上报的时候只有在那个消失的时候他会把这个市场给你算出来一起来上报
这样大家有好处就是你可以直接上报一个事件也不像我刚才说的一天还需要处理这么长的流程但是它有一个缺点对对对如果他太阶低测片的时候那个点没上来就直接丢失了对就被这受我们都拿不到啊对对对所以各有各的这个设计和实践嘛就是这里没有石油树裂对然后我们接着讲这个模块
模块呢其实业务方需要关心的就是这个模块的标识和动作比如说啊这个赞同它是一个按钮那它有一个模块ID然后呢这个模块ID的动作是什么呢是点击所以你要揣入Action等于这个Click然后Modern Identifier呢其实对应的就是Prov等等的就随便就定了然后呢此次Click的业务参数是什么呢就是它当前的赞同比如说有多少个啊可能就是ProvCount这样的一个参数
那剩下的呢比如说他点赞的是哪个内容实际上你在页面里面其实是可以拿到了嘛然后这个按钮又在这个页面里所以呢SDK这个层面可以去把他页面的信息页面的actual参数直接给灌进来这样的话其实就不需要业务房自己去收到买了啊对我理解如果一个页面所有的模块比如我们知乎的文章他底下有评论
有点赞反对其实他这个页面的所有模块其实可以共享一些信息的对他们的配件ID可能都是一样的对配件requestID是一样的对可能还有一些其他的环境信息也是一样的对没错没错是这样当然这里面也可以延伸一下比如说下个树苍也可以通过requestID去直接关联他页面的信息当然这些都是可以实践的一些东西但是在端上可能会容易的去做这样一些
啊事情主要是为了下游减负嘛就是啊这个其实就是一个啊这个衡量了就比如说你认为端上做更合适呢其实你可能就在端上直接去做啊对端上做了说他就轻松了是的是的说他做了端上就轻松一点是的是的其实就是这个衡量到底应该是给哪一个最合适的不是说每个一定要一定需要哪个做对这里其实可以简单举一个例子你比如说平时时的这种比如说我
点击一个赞同的这个按钮对吧那假如说我有一个这个推荐的系统然后呢我会根据你的实时流赞同数的多少来取决其他的用户啊推荐数的多少那其实可能在端上去和平这个数据是更合理的因为端上会直接把内容的信息在配置的actual里面去携带
把这个module的这个事件上冒上去那其实是实时那边就不太用关心啊荣誉的处理它直接就能去用对实时就能做的事情更少一点然后它能更快的去推进对对对是这样的对然后呢还有一个就是刚才说到有一个session ID的概念就比如说你打开一个APP一直到你关闭一个APP那其实中间你要把它拎出来实际上啊这里面会有个session和超时的概念
首先来说我冷启动肯定会有一个新的session但是有一些经典的场景你比如说我正看着知乎那忽然来了一条微信我肯定要回一下但是我回到微信去回复的时候可能几秒钟的时间我就回复完了然后这时候我再回来阅读知乎的内容那实际上理论上来说它是比较连续的一个动作如果你
直接根据切换App这种口径来切换的话它确实是比较粗利度的而且它切换的这种评评也太平反了而且你连不起来就是整个你前后的这些逻辑所以一般我们会设计一个Session的概念比如说用户5分钟或者15分钟但这个数值也取决于你App的类型完全没有上报的行为我认为Session是可以更新的你比如说
我进到微信之后呢我的支付其实一直就在后台了那这个时候其实我就不再用支付了那其实在打开比如说半小时之后了那我肯定是一个新的会坏但如果说刚才那种场景其实我回了一个消息再立马又回来了那超时时间我认为没有到那Session其实还是同一个Session那我继续去
做这样的绘画就行了但这个的话可能业务的同学不太需要关心但我觉得还是在买点模型里面挺有意思挺值得分享的一个东西就给大家说一下对但这里面还有一些比如说你业务方更新铺杀ID的时候它代表的是什么呢就比如说一个用户它看了之后但是它推到后台了
现在退到后台只有五分钟但比如说知乎会有一个机制啊我只知道比如说知乎会有一个动作会拉起这个进入到后台有段时间的用户比如说你的文章还没看完呢我只是下举例子然后你有把它换起了那这个时候你认为它是一个同一个系统赛事吗其实从我的观念来说它不属于为什么其实你这一次重新把它拉起的时候
隔得特别长对 也不一定是时间隔得特别长就是可能我认为比如说我App有一些机制比较小型机的机制我可能认为过了五分钟你还没回来我想让你继续回来那其实我就做这样一个机制然后呢我按新的session来做好处是说我这一次再回来我们归音到它是通过这样一个小心思把它拉回来的侧内侧内问题其实就可以分析这个东西推送这个
是不是就是有效的一个推送对是的是这样的对当然像类似的还有就是比如说外链啊等等的这里就不太详细展开去说了对所以其实这有很多的策略问题其实归位就是归位一个连续的筛行也可以不归位一个连续的筛行也可以只是看是不是和自己的公司对
自己的公司自己来来跑其实这个的话相对而言公司内部啊当然了公司内部各个部门也很难打成共识啊这个只能看自己的取舍了对啊大概是这个样子就是呃整个这块的话其实各家还真都不太一样这些可能策略性的东西大家可能不可能达成一个一致性的意见对那可能就是根据不同的公司制定不停的策略对
OK,整个这一页就讲到这儿,然后买点染色的一块儿,要不伍运来讲一下。好吧,一直做捧杆,做了半天的捧杆。现在我讲一下染色相关的东西。其实刚才袁世大老已经说了,数据归因其实分两种,一种刚才市政那种战外归因,就是启动的方面的。现在我说一种叫战内归因。
战略官员一般由端上来做去做埋怜染色端上是怎么做呢他会把所有的关键路径都带到事件里面带到后续事件里我们上报的事件中就会携带着所有的关键路径打个比方比如现在是Click2就是一个承担事件就是下单下单成功的事件它是有哪些事件连续组成的呢它有一个PVE页面1出现
然后页面以某个按钮点击进到页面2PVL然后最终在PVL第二个页面中去点击下单按钮所以一个下单它是由一系列的事件去组成的当然我们在每一个事件中我们都会写来上一个事件的信息这样我们关键路径的生命周期就可以分析到承担事件是有哪些
关键路径去组成的它可能由A、B、C到D也有可能叫A、C、D有可能直接A到D这样我们就可以做一些路径分析的方面东西我们可以分析到哪一条路径是用户最倾赖的当然我们也可以做一些load分析我们进行A、B、C、D我们A到B的时候可能只有百分之就是我们分析一条路径分析一条路径就是可能有A到B90%的用户还在B到C可能直接损失到30%了
C到D可能只有10%了其实这条路径就不一定是最好的所以我们经常通过这个染色去进行一些漏斗分析和路径分析的相关的东西OK 那就说一下我们怎么做染色呢首先染色就是刚才我已经说了从PVE到点击Click1到PVR到Click2这些买点时间都会带着所有的那个时间信息当然我们并不会
所有的买点都在事件信息的因为买点其实相关的东西它的数据量还是蛮大的它无论在存储上还是上包流量上都会很大所以我们会有一个回退逻辑比如我们PV1进到PV2再进到PV3再回到PV2那么我们认为它最终的路径是由PV2直接到最终的一个结果
其实PV3它只是经过了它并不是因为操作了PV3然后才到了最终的支付页面这样我们回退的时候我们就会把对应的PV3就是我刚才说了关键路径的信息携带我们回退的时候就会把这些PV3并没有对暖路径中的信息给排除掉OK当然我们这个sdk层面做会带一些PV可立可的事件
买点sdk只能感知到页面的出现和某个按钮的点击但业务方其实他可能也会关注某一些事件比如他做了一个比较漂亮的按钮他会可能在这个按钮上染一些信息然后看我们承担的路径里面有多少有这个自定应的染色信息去帮助业务方就是业务方去分析一些他们自己的一些自定应信息对我们
最终路径达成有什么效果就是那个custom tag的概念最终我们染色的数据结构是由kpass和custom tag两个方式组成最终他们上报到硕藏之后我们就可以根据它的kpass和每个kpass中写在的这些custom tag就是业务方染色的东西去进行分析然后这些信息对于那些订单支付事件
和定端时间和支付时间都意义比较重大对 这边可以补充一下就讲一个大数据的概念吧当然就是移动端的同学可能知道的略微少一些就是有一个东西叫UDF就是Udify Foundation这个我都不知道就是相当于你定义一个搜扣的时候其实在大数据里面你可以去扩展这个搜扣的能力比如说我这里面比如说大概
大部分的SDK都会做refer的概念就是我从哪个页面来对吧但是呢那个只能带单几比如说我从A进到B进到C那C的refer就是BB的refer就是A嘛那这个时候其实我B可以带A
但是C也可以带B但是C拿不到A的信息或者拿不到点击或者什么的一些动作其实这个买点染色就能补充这样的能力我们通过UDF的这种功能其实也可以实现这种Refers的能力
更进一步我们也可以像吴云刚才说的我们可以通过这种自定染色直到那个漂亮的按钮给我们带来了多少承担因为这些承担的信息里面有这个染色的我就认为是这个按钮带来的其实相对而言就简化了很多后期分析的这个工作和压力对其实我刚才说了关上的袁日老师补充了一下树苍那边是怎么做这些染色的那些处理的我也是树苍的
这个没办法就说一点我了解了OK那接上下一个话题就是买点方案的选型OK就是我先说一下常见的买点方案和知乎的实践常见的买点方案一般有四种一种就是全买点可能大家都用过另外一种就是全选买点就是可实化买点然后是声明式买点和手动买点我分别介绍一下这四个
全买点也叫无横买点就是无横买点就是我们业务方就不需要写任何业务代码就可以进行买点了当然都是通过我们那个叫lp的方式去拦截一些系统事件比如之前很早的就是打pv大家就会互可助pv就是那个就是rs的view controller出现view dpl会自动打一个pv但是
他有一些缺点什么缺点呢就是我们只关心某些页面的买点并不是关心所有页面的买点所以他就会导致流量成本比较高然后他买点信息也不准确因为他无法感知到业务的一些信息他只能感知到我这个微华控制了叫什么名字然后我可能起个类叫A然后埋上去的时候也叫A但是其实他们在数据分析的时候其实他就要知道A这个页面对应了真正的
可能叫首页,可能是社区首页他买点信息需要额外的进行加工还有一个问题是他无法避免收集隐私信息比如我一个输入框我可能是一个密码输入框因为我们进行全买点我们会针对某一个空间进行额外处理所以他就很难避免收集一些私密信息当然我也可以对某些空间处理但是这样就需要做很多额外的工作
而且有一些可能是你意想不到的对对对有可能我现在想的是密码数号还有可能有很多其他的想不到的点就是我们评估东西很难评估的特别重点第二个那个勸选卖点也叫可实化卖点可实化卖点它有一个好处就是其实刚才第一个全卖点就是它不管我们关不关注这个卖点都会上报可实化卖点呢它就可以勸选一些我们只关注的卖点
就降低了一些流量成本但是呢圈顯白點它對試圖的層級什麼之類的依賴性極強所以我們當我們進行代碼成功的時候它的試圖層級發生變化了那些圈顯白點其實就可能會失效然後後續的就有可能我們再做一個技術成功就是其實我們可能不知道這個技術成功會導致圈顯白點失效其實這樣很容易引發一些問題
当然第三种,声明式卖点,声明式卖点就是我们提前把对所有的那个系统空间进行扩展,扩展一些属性,然后业务方只需要停充它关注的一些内容,可能是刚才杨尔老师说的派解ID啊,或者是它的moduleID啊什么之类的,然后业务方不需要关注它的上报时机,有买点SDK直接去做就行。当然呢,
它有一个缺点就是减发成本相对较高因为它要对所有的系统空间进行扩展当然系统可能比如现在F16出了可能出现新的空间我可能就覆盖不到需要再做额外的开发OK 最后一种手动买点也许是我们最常用的手动买点它的优点很明显暗虚采集开发者可以完全自定义比如我这个按钮
它是什么按钮的模块ID啊什么信息啊其实业务都是可以感知到的它可以进行商报但它一个缺点就是研发成本比较高它会侵入我们的业务就是我们也可能写的按钮可能只是为了跳到下一个页面或者下单但是还有一个买点的代码侵入了但是这个而且开发成本也比较高但是我们可以通过一些配套的工具直接通过那个
买点平台就是我们可能有个买点管理平台生成对应的买点代码就降低一些成本然后因为如果刚才言论老师说的有一个确定的买点模型一个建装的买点模型是可以直接通过一些辅助工具生成买点代码的也可以通过辅助工具进行那个买点的验证的其实这样也反而降低了我们一些成本对这边可以我也可以补充一下就是当时其实我在
这个调研就是我们也会要做这种无恒买点的时候发现的max panel vp的一篇文章对是因为那个max panel可能是最早做无恒买点的但是现在max panel的vp就是在应该是在20年还是19年发了一篇文章然后就说他们放弃了无恒买点对因为他们发现在无恒买点使用无恒买点过程中刚开始很像在后续的迭代过程中会发现
带来的痛点远远比他享受到的那个就是享受到的那个好处要多得多就是他带来的痛点会特别多在后续的迭代过程中然后我们之后呢其实是结合了就是第三种买点方式和第四种买点方式两种方式声明是买点当然我们也也有就是一些自动化买点比如他那个在评施长就像刚才颜儿老师说的那种
我们当某一个页面出现PV的时候和页面离开的时候USDK层面给它保证了统一的在屏视察当然我们智库这边也对所有的空间都做了扩展然后业务方也是通过填充属性进行买点OK下面由盈人老师去说一下买点上包的色
然后买点生活策略这一块的话其实是结合着我们前面所有的买点模型来铺开的其实我们的日治其实目前是分了三个级别当然了后续可能还会有一个就是实时的这样一个概念就是在Z这个体系里面其实就是置换的lice就是我们日治商报里面其实是分了高优普通和低优这样三个级别的日治的
然后这三个级别的日治呢其实在端上其实都是用secret来做这样的一个缓存啊我们的啊这个逻辑呢大apm除外啊其他的这些用户行为日治我们一般情况下是不会丢弃的那我们会根据它的类型比如说高优是一件app级别的事件那为什么这样来设计呢比如说一个高优的事件那其实代表的是
它对于大盘指标是有帮助的你比如说App级别的App跟这样我们可以直接用它来计算DU的就是每个公司都很耽误对整个DU其实你只要上报上来这一个时间我就有了嘛对对吧难怪它是高用对对对然后还有一些普通的普通比如说我的一个点击我的一个页面曝光它虽然叫普通但其实它的约性级比App级别要低但是比其他的一些模块曝光还是要高的因为
这些场景比如说你的一个页面曝光对于某一个页玩意它可能也是最重要的指标所以它是一个普通远辑还有剩下的比如说某块曝光、APM的其他日子这都是属于DU的日子了对然后呢我们是做了分库和分表这里面其实有点类似于这个
就是后端所说的partition就是我们会把它能物理分割的比如说能分割到不同的表里面我们就分割到不同的表里面就高优事件它会单独享用一个表这样做的好处就在于我其实阿欧的成本会比较低我如果全都放在一个表里的话其实我的查询成本是偏高的其实我的写入成本都差不多
但是我的读取成本会偏高但这里面还有一些比如说可以优化的点比如说我前面提到了有很多的环境信息比如说4WH里面的3WH它的APP可能永远都是那个APP对它大部分都是静态的所以这里面其实还可以做一些比如说环境信息的合并然后事件体的合并这样也可以去压缩它的商包体积
然后呢还有一些比如说有一些公司的实践是说我把环境信息单独封张成一个实践这样上包了之后呢比如说类似我们刚才说的赛山ID或者赛山ID我绝对根据是对再给他串联那就说到我刚才说的那问题是前段来串联还是在书上串联当中对各有各的优点
对然后呢我们还做了一个啊买点年路的稳定治理比如说我们做了这个指数推避指数推避这个其实是针对于啊我们服务端的压力而言的比如说我服务端啊会报一些错对吧那可能是因为我的这个啊这个服务端的cpu已经被打满了呀或者是等等了一系列的问题吧或者说我的网关出现了一些异常啊他可能会报一些错误嘛那这个时候其实我端上就会延长他的请求
降低请求的频次延长请求的时间这样的话慢慢的把负担的压力降下来然后再次启动的时候那可能就比较容易那如果大家一直上报不上来因为买点这个事情比较特殊它跟正常的业务来看的话其实业务一天级更高对 一是业务一天级更高二是什么呢二是咱们买点SDK它上报的数量
它的上报 它是重上报 停下载的就是大部分我们的业务其实是破的过程更多而我们其实是铺实的过程更多嘛所以整个过程当中你必须要感知服务端那边的状态对 大概是这样还有就是金牙数据我们会连续想包因为比如说有一些DU事件它虽然是DU对吧
那其实我们会打包成一个大的Batch那这个Batch比如说我随便举例子每个工资不一样比如说他单次上包50条但你加了500条因为我们是一个轮巡的一个模型嘛那这500条如果你只是轮巡的话那要10次轮巡才能上包所以我们会做一个加数就我们会连续上包但是会保证同一时间只上包这个一个Batch对对大概是这样然后再有就是串形上包对
我们简单说一下后面吧 买点质量保障对然后整个这块的话我想给大家分享一点就是买点SDK上报质量是怎么样来做的就是其实对于APMR或者说用户的行为其实我们都会监控它整体的日治的上报情况其实我们基本上会分为
这个成功率啊延迟率啊然后包括啊你标识你的设备的发码的情况的监控啊包括一些关键资料的控制率啊控制率这个逻辑还要计算啊我这里重点说一下成功率和延迟率吧就是成功率这个东西呢其实啊sdk需要做到自证就是你没法跟任何的一个业务去比对因为所有的业务有自己买点但他们有一个呃app级别的就是能跟你实际保持一致的东西
去比对的所以成功率的话我们这边采用了一个就是序列号的概念就是首先这个序列号其实要声明一点就是如果你的买点sdk相报的数据都是按序按照顺序来相报其实这种统计方法是没有用的因为你最大的那个可能永远都是
你这个已经上报的那个那个那个调说因为我们刚才说了我们分为高优地位的事件嘛那高优的事件他Cyber分子不一定小所以我们会用那个最大的Cyber分子减去最小的Cyber分子作为一个理论值然后实际上报的驱虫的上报量呢作为一个分子来算我们的成功率当然这个可能也会有一个局限可能最大值并没有上来那所以整个这个成功率其实我们是会看一个趋势的
对所以他的理论值应该比实际值要偏就是成功率偏高那么一点点对对对大概是这样那延迟率的话就是刚才说到就是我们端上其实会有一个NTP时间嘛然后还根据NTP我们就是会标记几个时间比如说我
RTT时间怎么算就是通过发送那一刻到负担接收到那一刻我们通过NTP的时间较准之后它俩在同一个时间手上我们就能直接拿sever time减去send time来算我的网络耗时对对对然后GR时间就更简单了就是用send time减去用户产生日制的时间就是它在本地GR的情况
然后这里面我们就是监控体系里面除了这些报表以外呢还会有一些DQC就是所谓的质量对质量监控我们会配一些大盘和一些报警然后来做这些东西这个主要还是看一个比如说日式铜笔日环笔等等的这些东西周铜笔中环笔这样来看对对对对我想说一个成功率其实现在很少有人就是有一家公司就是尤其是那个
日火量比较高的一些公司同时接两套s买点sdkg对比的是的是的因为如果接两套他的日质量啊存储量啊非常恐怖对非常恐怖估计那个消耗不是一家大公司可能愿意花花那些那么那么多那个成本可能都是自整很难就是接两sdkg比较对然后那个
我这里给大家实操几个色扣吧因为端上同学可能色扣用的稍微少一点就前面提到的比如说我取第一个例子就是左边的这张图其实就是我们这个
日制计压的一个情况的一个计算其实这里面会用到了SAM和KISS的这样的KISS的一句然后来算比如说我从一个ODS就是比较贴远的一个数据来算我的整体日制的情况的时候我会便利我某一天的所有日制然后我把刚才计算的那个口径用进来就是Send Time 检测可能Time比如说大于
这个3600的那可能我就认为就是它的计压超过一个小时然后等等的还有几分钟多少的整体把它算出来然后我就可以算一个整体的计压的一个情况大概是这个样子然后还有第二个给大家决立的比如说我们在用户定位的这种情况下我们来看就是我们能采集到用户定位是一个GPS还是一个IP
这个的话也是一个kisman然后加一个嵌套这种的话其实对于移动端的研发而言其实基本上够用了举第二个例子主要是比如说你想分析一个小的场景的时候可能你就想知道说你的这个用户比如说你的版本占比你有的用户还没有升级你都可以跑这种简单的色靠来做对
然后还最后举一个例子然后比如说发码的这个监控其实刚才说到有一个叫多发码少发码其实呢所有的发码你都有一个对标那这个跟那个
就是刚才说的上报成功率其实不太一样的因为你找到一个对标的话你就没有所谓的理论值嘛所以比如说我们内部比如说我们有一个发码叫Client ID然后呢我们对标是什么呢对标的是RDFA那我们怎么跑它这个啊这边其实是一个多发码就是一个RDFA对应多个Client ID那怎么来跑呢其实你也可以做一个这种嵌套的一句就是你先把所有的
这个device的IDFV和client ID通过这种group by的这种语法就是看内部的那个括号里面那个select你把所有的组合先给它归并出来因为你group by了嘛所以它里面比如说一个IDFV对应了两个client ID那其实对应的就是两条记录那这样的话你再做一层group bygroup by IDFV的时候那你就能把对应的client ID的
各属给它跑出来了然后最后加一个Having的这种修饰服务然后我们整体上多发码的这一部分就跑出来了对给大家随便分享这个车口对都比较简单然后后面的我就简单过一下吧因为时间确实有点超时了然后我们买点质量保障的话其实会有一个系统的工具来保障
就是刚才铺垫了那么多其实我们所有的买点模型还是服务于业务的所以整条来说我们一个买点的创建和研发流程大概是这样就是需求方可能会提一些带买点需求的买点然后这个时候会交给我们的数据PM去设计然后买点设计之后会交给对面的RD然后RD认为这个买点能实现我就去实现了不能实现的打回让PM继续修改
然后RD买完之后我们就进到我们的买点测试里面买点测试其实是会根据我们当时的买点的模型设计的陆入情况来归纳出它对应的规则然后去做偏自动化的这种教验的然后对应的再去发版和回度然后再回归测试等等这些流程
对然后这边的话重点介绍一下我们买点的管理系统就是买点关系系统的话其实我们这边会有页面的定义还有一个动作的定义就是所谓的我们叫语异然后其实就是结合我前面的这些组合来把对应的这些规则创建进来其实这里面更多业务需要关心的就是自定义的这些参数
然后我们需要总结了其实就是怎么样把这个语义唯一的从一个买点的message里面给它处理出来然后去把这些它自定义的这些字段的职与给它做一些关联和对比对然后这个的话其实就是一个刚才吴俊英老师讲到的就是
我们怎么样去买点实施吗这边其实我们会做一个sample code的功能简单的把它复制过还可能稍微改一下然后就可以了对其实我理解买点开发就是需要很多的配套工具就是买点的管理啊买点的验证啊对啊就是需要通过很多配套的工具就能减乘到很多研发的开认啊时间其实让业务研发对特色开发
测试研发都接上他们大量的时间其实让他们更关注于业务对OK然后来电业证这边其实我们是接了几张图然后其实各家公司应该大差不差基本上都是通过这种抓包的形式来做但是我们这边可能会偏自动化一些就是你可以先宣传一些寓意然后对这些寓意进行先的教验并且我们是可以生成对应的测试报告
然后整体然后再交给下游然后做这种研发的这种不断的迭代了这里就不细展开了